ja ich habe das wichtigste thema des
tages mitgebracht professor doktor karl
lauterbach sehr tages jahren des jahres
der pandemie zumindest wer mich kennt
den wird es nicht überraschend dass ich
herrn lauterbach nicht unbedingt als
nächsten gesundheitsminister sehen
möchte aber ich finde es einfach
unanständig was die spd gerade mit ihm
treibt anderthalb jahre stellt man eben
ins schaufenster und profitiert davon
dass er auf jedem tv sender in jeder
talkshow in jeder zeitung ist dass jeder
bürger sein gesicht kennt weil karl
lauterbach nun einmal corona experte ist
und kaum ist die bundestagswahl vorbei
kommen hat man gewonnen da versucht man
karl lauterbach einfach abzuschieben das
gesundheitsministerium soll nun
unmöglich zur fdp gehen und wenn man
sich mal anschaut welche rolle karl
lauterbach bei diesen corona plänen der
ampel hatte in den letzten tagen die
antwort ist gar keine ich finde das
einfach peinlich und unanständig ja ich
habe ich jetzt einmal gefragt wieso ich
bin ja auch durchaus bekommt
gelegentlich etwas kritisches über die
spd zu sagen aber hier kann ich den
entscheidungen wie nachvollziehen dass
jetzt der herr laut für mich jetzt nicht
unbedingt die totale wirkung eines
strahlenden sympathieträgers ich kenne
sehr viele leute die ihnen eigentlich
eher ein ärgernis finden sie einige
sitzen auch in diese rücken da hier die
jetzt nicht unbedingt mit herrn
lauterbach bei und der honig sagt aber
die umwelt auf dem gleichen ball ganz
christian sagen was anderes wir haben
bei bild.de irgendwer ist beliebt da wir
haben eine unserer umfrage gemacht mit
sämtlichen spd politikern die man kennt
und auf platz eins war karl otto bryde
inhalt der spd als hat selbst nichts
geändert karl lauterbach war er noch nie
der shooting star der spd jetzt ist das
nach kroner auch nicht 130 der bürger
haben uns in der umfrage gesagt sie
wollen karl lauterbach im kabinett wir
wissen doch dass um fragen der bürger
wenig damit werde die shootingstars
innerhalb der parteien sind das ist den
parteien absolut und das kann man glaube
ich guten gewissens auch jetzt unehrlich
und unanständig kritisieren ich hab
einmal was machen sie da zu sagen also
unanständige ist es nicht parteien
dürfen eigene auswahlkriterien die das
muss nicht unbedingt die beliebtheit
beim volk oder die zahl der fernseh
auftritte sein das ist noch nicht
unanständig ich glaube auch dass der
entscheidende punkt ist dass er nicht
geschickt wurde es war eben gerade nicht
so dass die spd in die talkshows
geschickt sondern dass er halt einfach
da sondern dass er davon selber hin
gegangen ist und meine der spd-fraktion
mehr oder weniger über das fernsehen
ausgerichtet bekommen hat wie sie es
weitergeht mit der pandemie und das ist
möglicherweise dann nicht zu der großen
zahl von politischen unterstützung
geführt hat die man braucht um minister
zu werden aber was rede ich da also ich
meine ich habe mir ein problem meiner
partei als lauterbach mit seiner ich
sollte ja stimmt das war natürlich auch
eine gewisse mediale zuschreibung dass
er bis vor kurzem oder vielleicht auch
heute noch so als gesundheitsexperte der
spd eingeführt worden ist das war
offiziell nie er ist abgeordneter der
spd vergessen wir waren nicht hoch
positioniert auf der landesliste hat
jetzt klar sein wahlkreis gewonnen
chapeau aber er war nicht der
gesundheitsexperte der spd ich habe sehr
viele debatten hat sich die funktion das
ist da wo ich jetzt mal so will
eigentlich machst eine frau die
spd-fraktion die angst hatten die waren
auch im fernsehen statt ist es war
sabine dittmer an eine fränkische frau
glaube ich die also viele reden gehalten
hat die aber keineswegs deckungsgleich
war mit dem teilweise doch
kabbalistischen geheimnisvollen
alarmistischen tönen von herrn
lauterbach war manchmal den eindruck
kannte er ist erst dann glücklich wenn
alle weggesperrt sind also das war oft
auch nicht auf spd parteilinie und da
kann man jetzt von der spd nicht
verlangen dass in der koalition sagt ja
und unser mann soll aber der sein der
uns jetzt anderthalb jahre in den
talkshows durch magnetische getrieben
hat das war nicht nur die talkshows muss
man bei karl lauterbach sagen auch als
auch als kritiker muss ich ihm
zugestehen er hatte schon relativ viel
einfluss und zwar ganz weit oben er war
in sämtlichen runden des kanzleramts
feiert regelmäßig mit der
bundeskanzlerin telefoniert und der
vizekanzler herr scholz der hätte ja mal
eingreifen können aber ich glaube der
war ganz zufrieden mit der art
wahlkampfauftritten hatte auch hier
gegenüber im studio das interview mit
karl lauterbach über seiner falschen
prognosen also ich muss auch sagen ich
finde karl lauterbach sollte sich eher
bei den deutschen bürgern den schuldigen
für viele seiner falschen prognosen als
es wie jetzt sagen liebe spd bitte bitte
seid anständigen sich alle die spd gar
nicht an ich fordere von der spd einfach
nur 1 denn ehrlichkeit man könnte ja
beides machen es karl lauterbach
entschuldigt sich bei den menschen für
die falschen prognosen und die spd bei
karl lauterbach dafür dass ihnen so
behandelt wie sie neben man glauben muss
das ganz anders interpretieren dass man
sofort glasklar geworden in dieser rolle
viele potthoff ist natürlich mit leib
und seele journalist und er hat sich
schon phantomschmerz er spürt ist dass
das ärgernis lauterbach eine und regt
sich als
glücksbringer in der wildheit durch
jetzt erwartet ausfallen könnte aber für
mich auf das ganze das ist mir jetzt
ebenfalls auch ganz deutlich geworden
das hat auch beruhigende züge weil ich
habe dass du so bis in die schweiz ist
er der ruf des lauterbach getrunken und
zwar als kassandra hoch 5 kassandra war
eine optimistin verglichen mit der
lauter braucht was der alles an
weltuntergangsszenarien
verbreitet und wenn es die spd sogar der
meinung ist dass man den vielleicht
etwas in den rückrufen schieben sollte
zeigt mir das dass die chance dass wir
alle noch unser 80's lebensjahr
erreichen durch einigermaßen gegeben ist
dass die welt morgen nicht untergeht um
möglicherweise auch dass die spd auch
gemerkt dass vielleicht dieser herr
lauterbach zu kassandra mäßig unterwegs
ist aber für sie natürlich für die
bauleitung verhalten bleiben wird nicht
verschwinden mich ist das bitter aber
ich glaube die die die lauterbach
debatte und die fabrik so lange klinge
zurückweisung dann können wir auch
wieder über die laute
publics hole ich mir noch aber es ist
doch interessant mal über unbequeme
politiker zu sprechen die mit ihrem
eigenen partei nicht immer ganz warm
sind und da haben wir zufälligerweise
gerade einen sitzen aber wie fühlt sich
das eigentlich an erklären sie mal wie
ist das so wenn man es war mitglied
einer partei ist und auch sehr
erfolgreich politik macht medial bekannt
ist aber mit den eigenen leuten nicht so
ganz warm wird das ist schmerzhaft vor
allem weil es ja nicht immer so war also
vor zehn jahren
bin ich noch in das führungsgremium
jungen parteirat heißt es der partei
gewählt worden und war im eigenen
landesverband denke ich hier ist ja
anerkannt und wenn es da zu seinem
zurück prozess kommt dann schmerzt das
meine analyse ist ja ich bin im
wesentlichen da stehen geblieben wo wir
grüne mehrheitlich vor 20 jahren waren
und habe die verwandlung in eine partei
die den tourismus nicht mitgemacht weil
ich damit nichts anfangen kann ich bin
universalist ich bin der meinung alle
menschen sind gleich und ich bin gegen
diskriminierung hat sie es aber und ich
finde diese ganzen zerlegung der
gesellschaft in da sind die mit dieser
sechs orientierung und die mit jener
hautfarbe und jeder herkunft jeder
kriegt seine eigene spielwiese und da
darf der andere noch nicht mal ein buch
über den schreiben oder wirklich
imitieren und so weit dann ist das schon
kulturelle das ist mir vollkommen fremd
ich kann damit nichts anders auch common
sense vor den grünen mit das ist der
punkt also jedenfalls nach außen hin aus
und es ist nicht es ist nicht das alle
grünen so sind aber es ist dominant
geworden und deshalb ich nicht
mitgemacht und mich dagegen gewehrt und
dadurch ist eine zerrüttung prozess
entstanden der schmerz dass man sagen
was bei ihnen noch auffällt dass ich
finde es ein bisschen anders als bei
herrn eine klappe alter brauch das ist
der andere geschichte bei ihnen ich
beobachte einfach in diesen zum teil
sehr linken und grünen milieus eine
wachsende verzweiflung
eine verhärtung der positionen man hat
wahnsinnig mühe mit andersdenkenden den
eigenen reihen umzugehen weil man
offensichtlich etwas verunsichert ist
was die eigene position angeht das
beobachten wir nicht nur bei ihnen in
der see beobachten wir bei vielen linken
parteien dass sie angefangen haben
dissidenten auszuschließen wenn ich mir
vorstelle ich habe noch die alten
debatten darin gesehen wehner spd da hat
es doch geklappt in der spd oder so dass
joschka fischer da sind doch immer
wieder streitereien sind diese parteien
über empfindlich geworden